i always told myself  i draw the line i said after 40 years  old at 40 it's finished no matter what  happened it's 40 it's finished because i  know  that my best years are probably behind  me you know of course when i retired i  felt  that i might have left money on the  table maybe i could have stayed there  for two three four more fights maybe or  maybe i would have got hurt in the  process i don't know but i don't want to  roll the dice and take the risk i rather  retire when my stuck is high when i'm  healthy and i can enjoy the rest of my  life it's not a game we don't play in  fighting you say you play fight you play  baseball you play basketball but the the  consequences of a loss in this in this  in this sport it's way more dramatic  than it is in  another sport